hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast wood plastics bad plastics how
tubes plates and pipette tips can affect
your experiments I am Judy O'Rourke
elaborate and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
eppendorf eppendorf is a leading life
science company that develops and sells
instruments consumables and services for
liquid sample and sell handling
performed in laboratories around the
globe for more information please visit
eppendorf com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker Rafael Briscoe
via PhD dr. Grizz Kodiak is a field
application specialist responsible for
the consumables product portfolio and
eppendorf AG headquarters in Hamburg
Germany Rafael received his PhD at the
Georg August University göttingen or he
investigated regulation of gene
expression and cellular signaling
pathways involved in diabetes type 2
later he took a position of a
postdoctoral research fellow at the Max
Planck Institute for molecular genetics
in Berlin and led projects on functional
genomics of human dilated cardiomyopathy
I will now turn it over to dr. Chris
cobia for his presentation all right to
the thankful offered its introduction
and hello everyone from my side as well
and welcome to our today's webinar
casaste expect las six how to display
Sandpiper tips can affect your
experiments and well I have to admit I'm
really delighted being here today and
bring you this educational and from my
perspective very interesting webinar I
believe the topic we will talk about
here is still not very well recognized
and often underestimated in the
scientific community but as you will see
it can have a tremendous significance to
the daily routine in the laboratory so
let's move to the agenda for today's
seminar and first we will generally talk
about factors influencing essays in the
lab then in the second major part of
this seminar I will provide you some
review on different classes of labels
and their relevance in the lab and
finally I will provided some practical
recommendations on how to minimize the
influence of eligibles in summarize the
seminar at the end so let's move to the
first part typical factors influencing
experiments or essays in the laboratory
may be either specific and have direct
influence or general and those have
indirect influence on experiments and
this is what you see here in this slide
let's go to the first the s8 specific
factors here presented on the left side
of the graph and typically these are the
factors most researchers or those who
work in the lab are worried with and try
to control and these include force first
of all samples meaning their quality
quantity integrity and availability then
of course can reagents their quality and
performance and of course lab equipment
with features in quality as well last
but not least great influence on as a
performance has the preparation and
handling of the samples
on the other side there general factors
believed to have rather indirect
influence are often not commonly
controlled in the lab routine and these
general factors of very heterogeneous a
may include personal skills lab
temperature regulations and many others
one of the factors however which is
commonly underestimated until
potentially very important our
laboratory consumables and this is
exactly on one of the important topics
of this webinar the importance of
consumables in the daily life routine so
when we typically regard the consumables
and their importance in the lab work
flows it is often confined just to the
obvious features which are presented on
the left like lid tightness purity
grades or centrifugation stability these
are by no means important factors and
has important impact on the in
performance on your experiments there
are however other less commonly
perceived as important factors which as
you with the later may have even more
profound effects as commonly believed
and these factors are quality of
consumables and very closely related one
rituals there substances that may each
other consumers and influence the
experiments and basically this is the
scope of this seminar of this webinar so
let's recapitulate here the main
messages or goals of the seminar I would
like to draw your attention to the
importance of consumables and rituals as
crucial factor influencing your
experience also I'll provide you some
comprehensive information on different
vegetable classes and which classes are
critical and provides some examples on
specific examples on how these
substances can influence various SI
systems and last but not least i've
mentioned already
to provide some practical tips and
recommendations on how to access and
reduce the risk of affecting your
experiment through rituals before
however we proceed to the next chapter
let us do our first Paul and ask you
some questions I give over to Judy now
so the question is do you regard
consumable as important factors
influencing your experiment and your
choices are yes no or don't know give
you a minute to answer
okay so 73.1 percent of respondents said
yes seven point seven percent said no
and nineteen point two percent said
don't know thank you for participating
alrighty on thank you for participating
it's really quite well for us good news
I mean the awareness is there 73.1
percent is quite high scores it's good
to hear that multiply participant regard
consumers as important factor
influencing experiments it's very good
news for us and yet will of course
provided some more detailed information
why so so let's move to the next chapter
leachable and their relevance in the lab
and let me provide you first of all some
important definitions what Allah jables
and closely related and often mixed up
term called extractables so the two both
are essentially or chemical substances
which can be released from a given
container or consumable into the sample
or stored material under typical
conditions which include experiments
specific temperature time and solvent
types so example here might be for
instance leaching from a container to a
certain drug preparation or your
reaction under standard storage or
experimental conditions it means in
other words and this is important to
stress here that leaching may vary and
sometimes very much according to these
experimental conditions and depending on
these conditions different chemicals and
their amounts or concentrations may be
present in the sample and have of course
in turn different effects on your
experiments so this is very important to
to tres here they are very different
leachable scum compositions and
concentrations dependent on the
conditions on the other hand the
extractables are all chemical substances
that can be maximally extracted from a
given consumable under extreme
conditions so this is basically the
worst case scenario and typically these
conditions includes very aggressive
organic solvents high temperatures in
logging cube ation times so after
explaining these definitions let's move
and talk about reachable in their
influence in various areas of life and
first of all this is well still
relatively underestimated fact actually
reachable from various household items
and personal care products can affect
our health and in various and many
clinical studies performed all over the
world it has been confirmed that many
eligible classes particularly two of
those toilets and bisphenol A BPA are
implicated in various health disorders
in humans and while living in the modern
world means unfortunately we are
constantly exposed to various plastics
and eligibles from food and beverage
containers different you beings carpet
cosmetics and so on and high
concentration of leachable have been
unfortunately very often reported in
general population and their influence
may be variously a tropic very versatile
including reduced fertility and
reproductive tract abnormalities also
hormonal brain and behavioral disorders
but also they're very often implicated
in immune functions and various cancers
now as you see here leachable czar also
environmentally relevant pollutants
install aids bisphenol A and other
leachable have been shown to act as
so-called endocrine disruptors and
directly target nuclear receptors
transcription factors and by doing so
this array
is intracellular signaling pathways with
developmental and physiological effects
and these conditions are particularly
profound in amphibians in some of these
the examples are shown here and the
scale of the problem is indeed events
for instance at least eight billion tons
of BPA is being used in industry per
year and partially released into the
natural environment and of course as a
reaction to this several countries
started monitoring soliton vpa contents
and various product in canada and as the
first catch actually declare bpa as a
toxic substance let's move on so how
about the lab how about labels in the
lab are they relevant in the laboratory
and answer is yes very much and so as
you see on the slide it's actually very
famous science publications from Andrew
hall where he summarized his research
and actually pretty much shark
scientific community by showing that
substantial amounts of eligibles are
detectable in common laboratory plus
they were and they can significantly
affect in Harbor actually many as they
systems what he really showed is that in
fact the eligibles posed a likely source
of error in many SI systems so this was
kind of a shocking finding to the
scientific community and after this
publication a real flood of various
papers have been published often in high
impact journals where scientists from
different laboratories all over the
world were reporting growing evidence
for consumables affecting their
experiments and this in turn kind of
revolutionary scientific community and
led to conclusion that consumables
english' Buhl's were largely
underestimated by the researchers and in
the past and pointed of course to high
importance of high quality consumer
as important factor influencing various
laboratory workflows and of course this
continues we see here significance in
clinical diagnostics and as you might
imagine when I say go wrong in the
research while it's pretty annoying but
if this happens in Diagnostics well it
gains a completely new dimension of
significance it might mean the
difference between health and disease
sometimes the difference between life
and death and here it's ones romatic
example published in nature news from
Medical Center in Jerusalem which was
routinely screening patients for some
rare metabolic syndrome and all of the
sudden all of their patients all of the
subpoena subjects were basically
diagnosed as a sick and positive and
disappeared actually very weird since
the diseases are rare so it was actually
a real academic of course they stopped
and investigated their routine sa
methods and such a month of
investigations it turned out that
problems were caused actually by piper
tips they recently purchased and used
for sample preparation as later reveal
this effect was caused by a and died
civilizing agent and p10 used during
production process of the tips sergt
eligibles may have also profound
significance in clinical diagnostics
before we proceed to the next night we
would like to ask regain your opinion
and know some more information so it
ties the time for a new poll Judy I give
give over to you the question is how
familiar are you with the topic of
reachable situations are very partially
or not at all
you know that will make sure it's Barnes
okay so five point seven percent of you
are very familiar 71.4 percent are
partially familiar and twenty two point
nine percent are not at all familiar
with the topic unreachable thank you for
participating again all right thank you
for myself as well well it's indicates
quite high words of the topic quite I
mean the majority of you is partially
over it aware of the topic of literal so
it's really high score actually well
that's perfect we are really the
audience for this for today's seminar so
um thank you again for taking part in
the poll let's continue just close the
poll windows and so let's have now some
some more details and specific examples
on how actually tables can affect
various PSA systems in the laboratory
and here is one showing how rituals from
a regular micro test tubes can affect
enzymatic essays in depend on the left
you see bars representing an enzyme
activity in the presence of DMS oh which
was on the grizzly rinse through glass
control or micro test tubes here named s
tube and for information glass is
virtually free of organic substances and
typically regarded as negative control
in such studies and as you see here in
this example samples incubated in
plastic chips show up to forty percent
inhibition of this specific enzymatic
activity and there is a little also
little story to these figures we should
like to tell you now well this andrew
halt who publish this data in a ghe love
journal he is a pharmacologist and was
studying some promising drug candidates
and very much interested in their
inhibitory effects and some
and some enzymatic systems and after
years of research he found a very
promising compounds which shouted his
delight a considerably high inhibition
rates up to forty fifty percent these
effect was our variance table and upon
closer investigation appeared to be
basically related to the tubes he had in
his lab or more specifically application
being released into his samples namely
the laminate and as you might imagine he
was very much frustrated and it was
actually the very reason he started as a
scientist seriously investigating
rituals and their relevance on bioessays
so the conclusion here is a specific
example enzyme activity can be
significantly influenced by leaching of
bioactive substances from the lab micro
tubes let's continue so the second
example shown here investigates effects
of leachable on a receptor binding
essays and which is one of the most
commonly used SI systems in pharmacology
and drug discovery and in this
particular example here the preparations
of rat brain receptors were incubated
with their specific ligand and ethanol
washes from various laboratory tubes so
in the panel on the left side either you
see a percentage of specific binding of
the drug to its receptor in the
influence of different youths mainly
namely leachable from different
suppliers and as you can see they can
diminish drug binding up to fifty
percent of confer to class control well
notably eppendorf tubes show in that
identical results as a glass control so
the conclusion in this example is that
labels may affect receptor binding
assays this is another specific example
for you which one like to quote and
these were very perhaps specific essays
so
receptor binding or in the magic
activities but not only such as SH can
be affected also very simple also very
routine essays as in this case
spectrophotometric DNA quantification
can be hampered by substances glitching
from the lab tubes and as the title says
here it is really DNA you measuring well
not always and the data has shown here
originated from biotechniques article
published by Lewis and his group and
provides quite striking evidence of some
very mysterious nucleic acid molecules
appearing in pure water samples upon
short incubation what it's in panel a on
the left side is a perfect DNA spectrum
with a distinct peak at 260 nanometers
which is Merrilee a heterogeneous
mixture of uv-absorbing labels from the
lab tubes used to incubate water and
legible leaching process is temperature
dependent as we mentioned already and as
depicted in panel B in the middle
indicating that extended incubations at
higher temperatures will lead to more
leaching it absorbance and finally as
shown in panel see on the right leaching
may lead to kind of false DNA
amplification phenomenon which means
increase in DNA concentrations after
heating the sample as might be the case
for example in case of PCR reactions so
this is another specific example let's
move on these false positive DNA
measurements have been actually
investigated in more detail by our
application timid eppendorf and we
actually found this as a very quick and
easy test indicative of general ritual
levels and
single quality in this respect so
basically very quick test you could
perform your laboratory in our
experiments we did absorbance
measurements of water incubated in
different views for 30 minutes at 95
degrees and calculated theoretical DNA
concentrations resulting from the
absorbance at 260 nanometers in the
results are shown in the panel here are
quite striking even after relatively
short incubation times the amount of
foam DNA was reaching over to microgram
per milliliter the rest numbers over the
bars as you see which these
concentrations actually consider is
pretty high and sufficient for most
essays where DNA is used as a template
well of course in this case within do
any adoption as it surely might be just
frustrating because there is no DNA and
the sample showed also high readings
that's 280 nanometer which is typically
used to quantify protein and in this
case also leading to false positive
quantification so let me conclude here
uv-absorbing eligibles can falsify
spectrophotometric measurements of
nucleic acids and proteins and how about
the plates and the author is it might
get even worse so here we use the same
photometric essay and evaluated
absorption spectra of water samples
incubated in 96 depot plates and the
resulting spectra are shown here is
represent pooled samples of three
independent plate so it's important no
tears pool mean pulled samples from
three independent plates and most of the
plates from different manufacturer
tested showed high levels of
uv-absorbing little
and this was pretty much consistent with
our finding done with the tubes what was
however very surprising is showing the
next slide and in this graph the broad
red line represent of the ryans of 96
individual wealth of three independent
plates and indeed very high and this
actually the case that leaching process
per se shows very high variability and
potentially may falsify or increase
variety and ethics performed in platform
at so it literally means they're
dependent on the position of the well
different levels of lychee may occur and
therefore different effects on your as
they may take place it might be of
tremendous important for those who work
with different layouts dilution series
or tool are played position-dependent
ethics so this is actually quite another
dimension of the problematics is first
we have the eligible the dam they affect
the experiment and third there is a high
variety to the leaching phenomenon so
wrong we presented here some specific
examples of SI systems were vegetables
have been shown to be essential factor
influencing them and let's finally t
what are legible exactly and which
classes are critical so rituals chemical
analysis and basically if we made a
brief chemical analysis of typical
plastic you poor plates we have in the
lab we will see quite an interesting
feature in contrary to common belief
it's made not only of pure polished
polymer or polypropylene or polyethylene
and apart from polymer molecules
laboratory plastic contains various
polymerization byproducts like aliphatic
hydrocarbons oligomers Holocene clusters
oxidation products and many others but
also more interestingly it contains
various chemicals added during
production process additives and their
hydrolysis products in this group is
actually largely responsible for most of
negative effects rituals have on various
SI system the system so let's have a
closer look at the additives used during
the production process because these are
the substances making their problems and
there are many various additives used by
the manufacturers during their
production process of consumers mostly
to achieve certain properties of the
consu bowl or even often simply to
reduce the production costs and in the
table here are summarized most additives
and are grouped according to their
potential of negative influence on
various SI systems so first group
contains heavy metals used to catalyze
the polarisation and stabilizers and
antioxidants to stabilize the polymers
and to extend the shelf life on of
consumables and finally of course we
have pigments in case of colour
consumables and these substances in the
first group cannot be avoided during the
production process they have to be added
simply to make the polarisation possible
and make sure consumables remain stable
and reasonable for reasonable period of
time so they are regarded as potentially
uncritical and there is not much
evidence actually in the literature of
their effect on the experiments I would
like however to mention that dependent
on the experimental conditions as the
methods used particularly sensitive
analytical methods they also
might have certain influence and
experiments so this was the first group
second group depicted here in yellow is
potentially critical and contains
clarifiers used to increase transparency
so you have a very clear cheerful plate
is somehow suspicious already
anti-static agents to decrease electric
charge and quad heterogeneous group of
surfactants in detergents to disburse
pigments and there's other substances
and typically these substances can be
avoided in the production and as
mentioned have been shown to be
potentially critical in some SI sisters
in last but not least leads the really
bad guys in red you see the additives
that have been shown in many
publications to leach into the samples
impulse a likely source of error in many
and as a systems the word that these
substances can be actually easily
avoided in our edit simply to reduce the
production costs or make it faster for
example sleep agents I used to remove
the consumable from the injection mold
and basically it's the same as you make
pancakes so we put the butter in the
frying pan and basically to remove it
faster of course it makes it faster but
the fattest aim of the pancakes so this
is exactly the same here the injection
mold is basically the slip agents are
used to release the consumable from
objectionable factor that they remain of
course in the plastic and contaminate
the samples also the biopods or simply
antibiotics are critical in dorada to
prevent bacterial growth of the
consumables on the console's which might
happen if the production conditions are
not very clean and finally the
plasticizers they're actually the
classic eligibles insert mostly to make
the consumer less rigid and prevent
breaking so again
all the substances shown in red and
yellow can be typically avoided in the
production process of consumables and
are either potentially or critical
tumult of the essay systems and excuse
me here in this small literature digest
these dustins are indeed in my classical
papers dealing with rituals and have
been shown to make sometimes life of
scientists really miserable so what you
see here are articles were effectively
jables from different consumable times
are shown on various experiment or SI
system so in demotic essays
receptor-binding cell growth in
spectrophotometric quantifications and
since you will be provided this full
presentation of PDF i will not go into
detail of each of these papers but I
think it's worth to wait at least some
of them later so of course will be
provided is the whole presentation of
PDF actually connects us it's on the
downloads on the website later on so
let's summarize and makes an important
message in this seminar they are as
you've seen three critical classes of
substances use during production process
of consumables that may leach into the
samples and negatively influence your
experiments and these are sleep agents
by the sides and plasticizers and if I
were to choose just one take home
message from this whole same marabou
definitely this one so make sure you
remember you remember it well now i
think it's not scaring you in ensuring
the experiments spoiled by eligibles and
here i would like to give you some
practical advises in the next chapter
how basically to achieve to achieve it
and minimize the effect of litter balls
on your experiments before we proceed
however let's make me the another poll
and ask you a short question regarding
your experience with problems in the
during to consume so I give over two to
judy now the question is did you
experience problems in your lab routine
due to consumables and your choices are
often sometimes never or don't know
so six point five percent of respondents
say often 45.2 percent case sometimes
six point five percent say never and
41.9 percent say don't know so thank you
again corresponding to this pool alright
thanks again well let's say again from
our perspective interesting results so
it indicates really that most of you
actually have problems and these are
regulated to consumers some of you six
months five percent even very often so i
hope this seminar will basically provide
you in vital information how to deal
with this and this is actually the next
chapter we're going to now thanks again
for participation in the poll and so
let's go to the final points of
dissimilar minimizing influence of
eligibles practical recommendations and
first of all when we talk about
practical recommendations i would like
to remind you one of the first slides in
the seminar were a site-specific as the
general factors influencing experiments
were discussed in the general conditions
in the lab do include consumables and
labels and have to be considered and
controlled what is important here is
that this common mindset has to be
changed we're only reagents and
equipment influence your essay it is
also and this has to be kind of this is
the message here it is also consumables
and other related factors like rituals
that may have sometimes tremendous
impact on your experience and here are
some specific steps how to control and
minimize effectively jables first of all
it is advisable to do inventory of
consumable
you use in the lab very often we're not
even aware of what we all have and what
and why we use for a given context
permits so an inventory will leave a
good overview of your situation and
actually make easier to react when
problems will occur and very often they
will occur but typically we don't regard
consumables the cost so in the case of
false or variable or irreproducible
results it is always wise to consider
possible influence of eligibles on your
experiments and tests respectively
reagents water and consumables you use
standardization is also another very
good way to minimize effectively tables
so using same consumables even same
production lots will definitely decrease
the variety in their influence on your
workflows and finally good laboratory
practice is to order new consumers early
enough and always test them against all
batch in the same experimental
experimental setup these are basic rules
here in basic recommendations for you
how to start with that dealing with the
problem of eligibles in the laboratory
now another tremely important point in
the standard the despot superficial
similarity consumables are not created
equal and although Jude's platen tips
may appear saying to you they actually
significantly differ in material
manufacturing purity grades and their
performance and these differences occur
in the long process where consumables
care their production specification are
produced and finally quality control
takes place as shown in upper part of
the slide so the important message here
is the right choice of consumables is an
impact on the outcome of your essays
and so actually one of the most
important practical recommendations here
on how to minimize the influence of
legible is to choose right consumables
and firstly there are many companies
manufacturing consumables with various
technologies and production standards it
is therefore essential to choose those
manufacturers to comply with high
international quality and purity
criteria and are respectively certified
and there are some important questions
you definitely should hop and get
positively confirmed before choosing
consumer from given manufacturer and
this is what you see in this slide in
the development and production of
consumables according to international
standards I the norm certification is
important in particularly Isaac inform
cleanroom conditions as high level of
production automation is essential and
another important question to ask is
detailed information on quality and
purity of raw material used for
production should definitely not be
recycled and what are exact production
conditions and weather any additives I
used in which norms are fulfilled let's
continue and one very important point
which along with definitely help you
minimizing risk of leachable in your
life is to choose consumables which are
free of critical additives so ask the
manufacturer if they're consumables
absolutely free of sleep agents
bioscience and plasticizers and while
telling is one thing and providing in
certificates is another so it's very
important thing here to ask for
respective certificate also for
sensitive essays and sensitive
analytical methods like hplc or Molly
where possible choose clear consumables
to eliminate the influence of pigments
and accompanying substances is finally
it's always good practice to ask for a
lot specifics
regarding consumer with quality and
purity grades important here is the
certificates were issued by thermal
accredited laboratory and should be
really until Bureau of course available
online which is not always the case so
these are basically some specific
recommendations from our side how to
choose our good quality consumables for
experiments and of course a lot but not
least it's really important to get
professional support in case of problems
a comprehensive and duplication and
sales and application assistance from
the manufacturer size is actually very
important in case of difficulties with
your consumers and respect this
application he will save you time money
and of course a lot of stress and and
these were some practical tips and
recommendations on how to minimize
influence of eligibles and I hope it
will really help you avoiding major
problems and basically improving your
laboratory work laws and finally what do
recommends top scientists when it comes
to eligible while I feared smoke fetish
from Andrews halt article in a JT glob
colonel and he also is an expert in the
field of vegetables eligible guru as
what must one might say clearly
recommend purchasing consumables from
manufacturers they do not use additives
and basically avoid suppliers is refused
to confirm to confirm the absence of
such chemicals and one of such
manufacturers mr. dr. Hall recommends
after quite laborious searches eppendorf
I believe me we did not pay for the
statement is basically his independent
opinion as a scientist now and it's one
of the last night's one of my personal
recommendations in case you would like
to pay more information on leech
and there is significant in the
laboratory visit our very interesting
from my perspective are interesting
websites at eppendorf become / eligibles
where we place various information and
and additional resources on labels many
scientific articles pastors and other
sensitive data as well a of course
relevant happened or certification
regarding quality and lychee balls and
last but not least a very interesting
interview with Angie halt himself where
he talks about literals and he's
continuing research on on them
Unbeatables and we are slowly actually
coming to the ends of the webinar so let
me summarize the key points we covered
here I really hope to make it clear to
make clear this point and make you
realize that despite common belief
consumables doing these play a vital
role in the laboratory work well and I
also hope this similar provided your
good ratio on various additives use
during production process in how these
chemicals by leaching to the samples may
hamper many SI systems as an important
point please remember the three classes
of additives which are critical and
shown in the literature to effective
experiments of sleep agents plasticizers
and bioscience and finally I hope it's
also clear choosing high quality
consumables free of the critical
additives can significantly reduce the
risk of negative influence on the
experiments and like to end this webinar
with this little cartoon from a German
pretty well known journal named lab or
journal which shows how a lot micro test
tube doesn't want to cooperate to
cooperate and say to the scientist well
translated from German well if you and
you have to live with this if you take
the cheap material and this apart from
teaching you some German of course I
think we
like pretty well current development and
changing the awareness of scientific
community regarding consumables and
leachable in their significance in the
laboratory and from my side thank you
very much for your attention before we
continue we have the last Paul for you I
give over to Judy again and so the
question is was this webinar informative
for you yes partially or no
wait another moment
game 90.3 percent of you said yes the
webinar was informative partially nine
point seven percent and no one said that
it was not informative so thank you very
much well that three nights result so
really glad and to hear that I was
interesting for you and well we are
ready now for some questions this is one
of the good points of this kind of live
sessions that basically after you can
ask your specific questions and we'll
try our best to answer them so let's go
to Q&A session and you know that
employment oh can I may I thank you for
that informative presentation just
before we get started on the question
and answer session I would just like to
remind the audience how to knit question
so they can submit questions by typing
them in the Q&A box which can be found
by clicking on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window and we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can and the first one is
what are exactly the uv-absorbing
leachable chemically
how should I should I repeat that one
sure so if you would read the first
question I think what are exactly the
uv-absorbing eligibles chemically right
yes so on generally speaking mouth
organic compounds actually do absorb to
some extent at least UV light and
highest absorption levels show usually
are not a hydrocarbon so phenol groups
and double bounce and typically these
are numerous additives with fennel
groups for example phenolic antioxidants
stabilizers clarifiers and their
oxidation products so these are
basically in most cases the uv-absorbing
eligibles our vegetables only relevant
for a phase with incubations in higher
temperatures yeah well indeed from
leaching is temperature dependent
process and generally speaking they hide
the temperature the more leaching occurs
there is however extensive scientific
evidence that many critical additives
like the patient's biocides for example
can leach already and strongly
influenced various experiments in lower
temperatures already also in room
temperature so example includes various
in somatic essays receptor binding and
many others in the end it is difficult
to predict which essay to which extent
will be influenced by given additives I
think it's the best practice will be
here to avoid the criticals the critical
additives completely most of the data
you show refers to tubes in place what
about tips might they also have some
influence on the experiments yeah
although they contact time of samples
with the material of the consumables is
indeed shorter in case of type of tips
then it is in tubes or plates they may
also have
influence on the experiment in some
examples were provided in the
presentation actually so irukum it is a
flip agents from pipette tips and has
been shown to inhibit g-protein coupled
receptor essays or Die solubilizing
agent hibited mitochondrial and chain
respiratory chain enzymes this is this
diagnostic case which has been shown in
very sensitive analytical methods like
hplc or maldi also may be affected by
leaching from tips and there are many
more examples in the literature in
general the more sensitive they say or
the method the more likely leaching from
pipette tip may influence it okay this
next one is a two-parter the dip and or
fuse critical attitudes during
production of their consumables and can
a respected certificate be obtained yeah
during the production process of
eppendorf does not use an additives
which have been shown in the literature
to be critical so we don't use any slip
agents besides and plasticizers it
refers to all consumables so all cubes
place and tips and we indeed do provide
respective certificate of quality we
call it coq so certificate of quality
which is of course available online and
in each product package can i use the UV
reaching test with water intubation to
check the quality of tubes i use in my
lab yeah well in in this test one on the
one class of leachable is actually
evaluated the uv-absorbing eligibles
which is which are important but not the
only one which has been shown to be
critical so there are other classes
which will not be visible in this test
and still may be present in they given
consumable or an influencer acid so
level levels of uv-absorbing lietuvos do
not necessarily mean that they are
absolutely safe also the conditions of
the test and measure
ment of the spectra has to be optimal so
that the results are reliable and using
diluted samples or too short incubation
lately too low signals and basically
unreliable readings so I would say the
take home message here would be the UV
legend tells may be done for some brief
evaluation but I would still be cautious
over absolute statements and there might
be consumables giving low absorption and
still actually probably having high risk
of hampering your experiments even Giles
plastic oh yes if the type of plastic
relevant PS or PT etc yeah well the PS
is polystyrene PP is poly problem and
they had completely diff chemically
speaking different plastics and there
are different sets of polymerization
byproducts which you will see and also
different additives use user in the
production process so definitely it's
relevant and from my perspective are the
PS is much less resistance to higher
temperature so theoretically it
basically might leach more than PT why
do you recommend clear plastics well
it's simply because it's colored
consumables colored plastics have some
additional more additives regarding
exactly the color so there are the
detergents there are the substances
dispersing this dice and basically mouth
of the guys also can be found later on
as eligible in the example so whenever
possible our really for sensitive
methods analytical methods would try
toward just with the clear consumables
in your slide 19 why are ssdna 25
nucleotides in to be
8 30 minutes at 95 degrees centigrade it
as we know TC are key to the samples
only five minutes at 95 degrees
centigrade yeah well this is a
experiment with this is basically
conditions which we which are published
and this is actually to better visualize
and they basically make this more clear
you have to remember that PGR takes
place and over what the disciples are
heated for five minutes by this
repetitive process so in the end is
basically you have let's say 25 30 steps
and each of those includes 95 into
temperature or 64 relegation and
basically it's a cumulative process so
in the NGO has a very similar profile we
tested this is basically with the normal
pcr or a standard incubation at 30
minutes 95 degrees and the results are
quite similar the next person thank you
very much for your informative talk and
says they actually have the other side
of the problem with samples being
especially low concentration ones
getting absorbed by plastics you plan to
have another talk to cover this aspect
yeah well it's very pretty well known
phenomena the biomolecules protein who
played assets and bind to surface of a
plastic typically polypropylene and it's
basically due to certain hydrophobic
domains which the some molecules contain
and upon binding of course first of all
you have left material and second and
there is a certain limitation and a lot
of activity and so we have certain class
of consumable so-called lobe lines which
basically addresses this problem and if
there is of course interest regarding
this topic well willing to provide such
such webinar so thanks for for the
information and I think it's very
interesting topic actually so why not
doing another webinar on this thank you
next one is if there
way to test our consumables for the
presence of these agents besides testing
in our assay which may be hard to run
chemical tests absorbance hmm yeah I've
mentioned one of these very simple test
might be it might be performing this
uv-absorbing test and which is basically
incubating water and doing the
spectrophotometric measurement this is
not probably all of the little balls so
as I mentioned already it might give you
some indication but I will be still
cautious the back of course would be
hplc and but this is coffee and very
complex methods India and the best way
and this is one of the recommendations
for the firm this webinar is to be on
the safe side and basically purchase
consumers from manufacturers which do
not use critical additives um the next
person says are you going to repeat this
type of presentation in the future since
this is my first time to attend it live
I will just add that on this
presentation will be on demand for six
months I don't know Rafael if you want
to answer further well yeah this is
actually what we do we provide this
presentation on demand is on top you
would lie if you would like to have a
PDF of the presentation will be
available on the microsite as a download
if you have any questions of course and
your mind email is provided there so
basically you can address any questions
writing directly email to me and so yeah
I would remain with this actually here
ok the next person thanks to again and
says I have a question whether you
perform some experiments flash assays
about reaching of attitudes etc before
marketing your product and do you think
we must ask our suppliers about such
assays before we purchase plastic ware
yes we do
reformed routinely quality task and well
restore the first of all we start with
specification product specification and
of course we're all of the consumables
there is no critical additives but yet
we we do do the tests general leaching
of all of the organic substances so we
routinely perform such tests and I do
recommend that you ask your supplier
about how basically they address this
topic if they test it if they certify it
and what is basically they're setting on
this how does reachable to fetch samples
or a phase when stored at lower
temperatures how do with the focus yeah
as I said there is it's a very complex
process actually and it's a diffusion
there are some chemical reactions taking
place but in the end there are different
classes of different substances going in
different temperatures and times into
the sample so basically the key message
here is basically if you avoid
consumables with critical additives you
are on a set price but to answer the
questions how basically they affect is
very difficult it really depends on
their on the exact conditions in the
experiment so basically the solvent you
using the temperature and the time or
critical factors here and if you're
interested in particular essay for free
imagine your essay basically we're
willing to provide the literature on
where you can basically search through
and find if there is any information on
this it's very difficult to say if for a
particular essay and they've given the
given temperature there is an effective
deletable okay next person says just
wondering about the manufacturers that
were compared during the internal lab
tests at eppendorf how stable are the
Corning consumables in comparison with
eppendorf with respect to each
especially the culture flask yeah well
and there was an educational webinar we
will not provide any specific
information on the competition this is
not our policy here but of course if
you're interested this part part of
these results are published in
scientific journals and we would like if
you interested we provided the articles
here let's leave as a company of the
manufacture we don't provide names on
competitors or details and competitor
comparisons here here's nothing for you
what about the effect of reachable on
long-term storage conditions yeah most
of these papers of the data regarding
short-term effects but I might imagine
and the time factor plays a huge role
here and the longer the time the morally
jables you have and in most cases also
the temperature takes place is kind of
tricky to to predict in my opinion there
is just one paper I think regarding this
so far in the lump in generally speaking
we don't have much data on the long-term
storage so it's still kind of under
evaluation and I think there will be
coming scientific papers in this so at
the moment we don't have much data on
this okay and why are those two
wavelengths used 260 and 280 in order to
measure beach involved again as you
might remember we were showing the whole
spectra and 260 is basically the
prominent pic were most of this
uv-absorbing eligibles absorbed and
actually it's a peak where DNA absorbs
as well so this is the wavelength which
we chose to basically quantify the false
concentrations of the give
molecule in this case DNA and 280 is
protein typically used to quantify
protein so to answer shortly the
question 260 was chosen to simply say
how much for DNA you would have and 280
how much false protein you would have
how can you be sure that an experimental
result is influenced by consumables or
leachable and not by other factors yeah
this is a good question is always it can
be many things actually so can be the
equipment can be Regents can be the PhD
students and the best way is actually if
you have an experiment and you suspect
there is something wrong with it just do
the same experiment with different
consumables and one of the consumables
should be a good quality so without
critical additives of course the best
way would be to control with the glass
but I'm pretty sure it's not always
feasible so we use glass as a negative
control in your experiment who would be
the best option if not choose the high
quality consumables which are free of
critical additives okay it looks like we
may have run out of time I would once
again like to sail shocker Rizzo key
Crisco he asked for his presentation do
you have any final comments or file well
from my perspective was very good
webinar and judging from the
informations we got from pollings the
awareness is very high end which is very
positive and I enjoyed very much and I
wish to all of the participants could
live with their experiments and thank
you for the attention thank you I would
also like to thank our sponsor eppendorf
for making today's educational webcast
possible questions we did not have time
for today will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing
through april 20 6 2016 you will receive
an email from lab roots alerting you
when this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to for that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event faq and
the presentations PDF will be available
for download after the webinar in the
resources section of the microsite see
you next time bye